when god emperor of doon opens Malky is
the Ixion ambassador all accounts say
that the lord Leto was quite fond of
monkey and that they shared many private
discussions on various taboo subjects
the god Emperor saw that monkey
possessed the a studious character of
the icks e'en people and also enough of
their immorality to make him a balanced
human Leto saw as well that monkeys
weakness was his hedonistic nature Malky
was prone to bouts of pleasure seeking
and self indulgent behavior my uncle
Maki often said that the Lord later was
given to moods of great tolerance for
selected companions because of this
monkey shared intimate knowledge of
Latos true nature and of the golden path
Maki and the ex Ian's would however turn
this fact against Leto
they created weinery and raised her for
one specific purpose the purpose of Wu
and the God Emperor weinery was a mirror
of monkey
she was his opposite in everything
including sex weinery had been created
by the Exxon's using knowledge provided
to them by the Tleilaxu she was made
from a few cells of monkeys body and was
born and raised in a no room a machine
created by the Exxon's to hide what's
inside from the prescient eye the been a
Jesuit suspected that monkey like
weinery was bred by the IXY ins with the
context that he would be the official
exeunt representative at Latos court
Malky from his conversations with Leto
would eventually come to understand that
Leto was constantly seeking originality
and newness but that he was also aware
of the potentially destructive nature of
unpredictable things he would gain many
other insights about the god emperor
over their time together
monkey unlike many others in the
Imperium believed in the existence of
Latos other memories because of his deep
understanding of Leto and his apparent
sympathy for the god Emperor the IXY
inquisitors believed that he was overly
fond of the worm
in truth machi was the only one who saw
through the god-emperor machi saw how
Leto being as powerful as he is
contended with the desire to self
delight his slightest whim commanded
such power and obedience could he resist
what he truly desired most if it was
placed directly in front of him
Leto could not resist weinery
once he met her it was love and human
connection that the God Emperor desired
most Mulkey discovered this Leto also
tolerated Maki and the ick cience
because he buys from them often without
eggs Ian's devices Leto could not even
record and conceal his journals Maki
understands the fact that Leto needs the
exams as well technological innovators
know you are criminals of science in my
Empire Maki had laughed irritated Leto
had accused why tried to hide secret
laboratories and factories beyond the
Empire's rim you cannot escape me yes
Lord laughing I know your intent leaked
a bit of this and some of that back to
my Imperial domains disrupt cause doubts
and questioning Lord
you yourself are one of our best
customers that is not what I mean and
you know it you terrible man you like me
because I'm a terrible man
I tell you stories about what we do out
there I know it without your stories but
some stories are believed and some are
doubted I dispel your doubts I have no
doubts which had only ignited more of
Mulkey's laughter when Leto is nearly
killed in an attack by a lakh suface
dancers he realizes that the reason he
did not foresee the attack was because
of the fact that he could have died
later had chosen never to predict the
moment of his death but he also realizes
that Mulkey is the only one who could be
behind the attack
I could have died out there he thought
that began to explain why he had not
anticipated this attack but there was a
deeper reason Leto could see that reason
rising into his awareness a summation of
all the clues what human knew the
god-emperor best what human possessed a
secret place from which to conspire maki
Leto commands the Benin Jesuit sister
Antioch to help him locate Maki when his
fish speakers came upon the place where
Moki hid there was violence Antioch was
killed in the assault the guild and the
Bennett laylax had wanted monkeys secret
the no device which hid him from fresh
science they had attacked before Latos
fish speakers could the secret of the
IXY and no devices was spread to many in
the Imperium monkey was brought to the
God Emperor alive Lord Leto monkeys
voice was little more than a husky
whisper his eyes turned right focusing
on the majordomo and Monet Oh forgive me
for not rising to the occasion are you
in pain
Leto asked sometimes monkeys ayahs moved
to study his surroundings where are the
Ori I am afraid I must deny you that
pleasure Malky just as well Moki host I
don't really feel up to their demands
those were not Ori you sent after me
Leto they were professional in their
obedience to me
Leto said they were bloody hunters
Antioch was the hunter my fish because
were merely the cleanup crew while
listening to the conversation between
the god Emperor and monkey manao got the
sense that he was witnessing an exchange
between two superior beings who viewed
him as an object of amusement and
excluded him from the conversation Maki
had given Latos fish speakers the name
ori long ago the name had stuck it was a
reference to the beautiful young
virginal women that would await a
faithful Muslim in paradise according to
that ancient mythology Maki often had
indulged in Latos Hori just a few tiny
cells from my bath
Malky said then the carefully nurtured
growth and education everything an exact
opposite to your old friend Maki we did
it all in the no room where you cannot
see but I noticed when something
vanishes Leto said the no room manao
asked then as the import of monkeys
words sank home you you aren't we that
is the shape I saw in the shadows later
said manao looked full at Latos face
Lord I will call off the wedding I will
say you will do nothing of the kind but
lord if she and Malky are man hail Maki
hast your Lord commands and you must
obey that mocking tone manao glared at
Maki manao seems to resent anyone who he
interprets as being closer to the god
emperor than he he in part dislikes the
Duncans because they share memories with
Leto from their time together during the
old days on Arrakis the same is true for
machi who shared a mutual awareness with
Leto that when nail was not let in on
Leto could not kill Maki or command his
death for reasons of admiration as well
as others manao understood the
implication however he knew what it was
that God needed from him
Leto Maki called from behind him Leto
heard the litter grading on the wind
scattered sand which peppered the floor
of his airy once more Maki called
Leto you are the best there is no evil
in this universe which can surpass a
sodden thumb shut off monkeys voice a
blow to the throat
later thought yes manao knows that one
there came the sound of the balconies
transparent shield sliding open the
rasping of the litter on the rail then
silence manao will have to bury the body
in the sand
later thought there is as yet no worm to
come and devour the evidence Leto turned
in
and looked across the chamber manao
stood leaning over the railing peering
down down down I cannot pray for you
monkey Noah for you manao later thought
I may be the only religious
consciousness in the Empire because I am
truly alone so I cannot pray monkeys
actions had threatened the golden path
so it was necessary for Leto to
eliminate him but that does not mean
that the act of doing so didn't cause
him pain ultimately monkeys plan did
succeed to an extent if not for we nori
Duncan Idaho likely would not have
contributed to the murder of the god
Emperor it was later love for we that
was his downfall
but the exons however could not disrupt
the Golden Path it remained despite all
their scheming
Malky was a mortal man but the only one
who seemed to be a match for the god
Emperor
Malky knew God better than anyone in the
Imperium he was an outsider and yet he
saw the golden path and he saw Latos
weakness hi guys as always I couldn't do
any of this without the help of my
amazing patreon supporters Trini girl
and share a Valentine are my top two
supporters so thank you guys so much and
if you want to help support this channel
click the link in the description
you